let's ask Benji buddy has a mind here as
long as he's doing it whoever gets hard
he wins ok the Kolar have to guess in
advance for Howard's book that's a great
way to do you want to turn into
promoters down yeah alright they just
want to do is your lotion lotion
oh that microphone well Benji need a mic
on his headphones mic you're gonna be in
the line of fire let's go to Mike Mike
who in order to win the book you have to
guess who will get hard first Richards
probably already hard to thinking about
no he's not yet yeah but then jeez
rubbing my legs I didn't quick my you
want to play this or not rich will be
the first to get hard all right here we
go
I'm gonna try buddy wait are you Sal you
just give me assets okay you want
confess yeah I guess think I don't want
to get close obviously how are you gonna
get ahold of his [ __ ] it's completely
retracted I don't know this is known all
right you've never given a guy [ __ ]
no myself that's it all right all right
have you ever been in Sal's state when
you've given yourself and all right you
bet you're putting lotion on your hands
right okay and go ahead hurry this up
I'm disgusted oh and I wish I was shaved
for this first person to gross
oh my god
what are you doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]